１７×６－２＝１００♪
僕だよ☆
カントリーマーマレードボーイだよ
今日はー
みんなにすごいことをしてあげようと思うんだ
わかるだろ
ここにあるカントリーマアム１００個を
カントリーマーマレードボーイが全部食べちゃうわけよ
僕は見た目ちょっとひょろひょろしているが
そんなことは関係ない
全部この体で食っちまう
Body(?)
まぁ見ててくれや
結果はこの動画を見たら一目瞭然さ
さぁ、さっそく食べていこうと思うぜ
非常に苦しいチャレンジになると思うけれど
みんなの声援があればきっとできるはず
アングリー　イヤー
おーけおーけー　そー　おーる　かんとりーまーまれーど裸にしてここに乗せるナウ
すぐ食べれることが一番大切なこと
あ～れ？ちょっと多いか？
あ～　いぇ！想像してたよりちょっと多めですけどカントリーマーマレードボーイにとっては全く問題ない。
一つ当たりのカロリーを調べてみますと
バニラ一つ当たり４８Kcalってことは
４８×１００だから...４８００Kcal !?
No problem
これ全部食べると４８００Kcal
まあ、朝飯前ですね。成人男性２人分ぐらいですかね
まあほんと僕、お菓子の大食いがしたくてしたくてたまらない一年だった
では、いただきます
フォウ！いやもう多分ね全然いける
（陽気な音楽）
やっぱ、バニラに限りますよ。中のチョコチョップ...
中のチョコチップがおいしいんですよ。
（陽気な音楽）
多分１０個ぐらい食べましたが今日はほぼご飯何も食べてないからおなかは空き空きの状態。
味的に飽きは来ないんであとは僕の腹が持つかどうかという戦いになっています
陽気な音楽♪♪♪♪ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
甘すぎてちょっとやばいのでお茶を飲みます。
うわ、すごいなぁ
この時すでに...マーマレードボーイは...限界に達していた。
あーやばい。何個目？まだ六個目？
うゎ...うゎぁ...うゎぉぅ
あの、おもったより一個一個が強い
一口クッキーみたいに見えるんですけど...分厚いんですよね。詰まってる。
おもい。一粒が
おいしいね！だからこそ！
（汚い食べる音）
はあ、はあ、はぁ、はぁ
やばいやばいやばいやばい
もってかれそうもってかれそう
マアムがここまできてるやばい、持ってかれそう持ってかれそう
やっぱ結構減っては、減ってはいるけどいるけどまだ全然だなあ
（ダンッ（机をたたく音））
はあ、デッドライン
AH～
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！マジでやばいこれちょっとこれほんとにカントリーマアムじゃなくなってきてます。ちょっと
もうちょっと頑張ってみます。
（謎の踊りとミュージック）
I'm a hangr(ry
うううううううう
いやほんっともう無理もう無理
すみません！これ以上食ったらマジで多分ぽっくり行くんで
牛丼食いてえマジ
おいしいけど百個は無理でした。
すみませんでした!!!!
（怪しげな音楽（でーーん））
その後、カントリーマーマーレドボーイは謎の死を遂げた。
ていうのは嘘だが
何故だかおなかが痛すぎて一日中寝込んでいたのは
誰も知らない
（不気味な音楽）
うわぁーー
はあ、くくくくく
５１個残ってるんで４９個食べました
はあはあはあはあはあはあはあ
（ムシャリ）
（どーーーーーーん）